piers morgan has decided to leave the
itv
breakfast program good morning britain
he's been
outspoken in recent days about harry and
particularly
about megan itv confirmed his departure
in a statement saying it had accepted
his decision
and had no further comment to make
let's go live to our correspondent lucy
cotter good evening lucy so he he
literally walked out
this morning for a period um then he
came back and now he's
he has walked out
uh yes it's been a turbulent time over
at good morning britain in the last
couple of days this morning piers morgan
stormed off the set of the programme
after
his co-presenter criticized the way he
had been talking about commenting about
the duchess of sussex
and her interview with oprah winfrey
uh in the last few minutes itv have
confirmed that pierce morgan
who has been the presenter of the
breakfast show on itv since 2015
is leaving the show in the statement
they said following discussions with itv
piers morgan has decided now is the time
to leave good morning britain
itv has accepted this decision and has
nothing
further to add now this comes after
it was announced by ofcom that it was
launching
an investigation after it received over
40
000 complaints following yesterday's
episode of good morning britain
and that's more complaints than were
made after britain's got talent last
year and also
after celebrity big brother in 2018
both of those uh reached around the 25
000
complaints marks now pismorgan
has faced mounting criticism over the
last uh couple of days about the way he
responded
to megan and harry's interview with
oprah winfrey uh particularly comments
he made uh that he didn't believe the
duchess of sussex and her disclosure
that she had had suicidal thoughts
it has led to a lot of criticism
including from the mental health charity
mind
which came out and said it was concerned
and disappointed
by these comments as i said pierce
morgan
is leaving good morning britain
following discussions
with itv and uh it's not clear at all
where he's going to go next i assume
it is absolutely not clear at the moment
uh but given the fact that there are uh
a few uh new and news channels
uh starting in the next few months um
who knows his phone could be ringing off
the hook as we speak
yeah you're absolutely right a bit early
to say that but okay lucy thanks very
much indeed